i think that is actually a like
borderline criminal statement what you
just said
[Music]
what's up i'm nikki cash and i'm here to
answer the internet that was two that
was two like uh sales guy don't worry
about it
uh you're gonna start me off with a
rough one marry [ __ ] kill italian food
mexican food chinese food chinese food
it's gone i can do it at the lo mein uh
italian food i gotta marry because i got
people who uh are part of my family are
gonna watch us i like tacos but only on
tuesdays but any other week i'll uh i'll
eat the uh italian food he didn't marry
his eyes like the whole thing no no i
wouldn't
if you go to any sporting event ever
which would it be the super bowl no
which one like a specific game like oh
oh when lawrence times kicked the field
goal for the giants to go into the super
bowl when was that i think i was like
eight years old i remember i choked on a
popcorn colonel when it happened on the
tv and i was going nuts i even know what
was going on i started crying you taking
that game with like a helmet catch i
respect that thing yeah no no no the the
field goal kick was like the most
exhilarating
experience ever like being a sports fan
if you had the ability to spray like a
skunk what type of smell would you want
it to be that's a deep one because you
got to think about it like when a skunk
sprays it's cause it's afraid why are
you going deep with it i would have just
been like i like the smell of uh none of
tomatoes from italy so
if someone's coming up on me and i got
to spray him to get away i do that dior
souvage cologne that thing is the most
overrated cologne it should be outlawed
that's what i would do would you rather
take on a mama lion with just a dagger
or a pack of eight wolves with just
eight bullets and a gun i trust myself
i'm taking on the wolves with eight
bullets
easy easy easy yeah you gotta bet on
yourself what are you gonna do you know
what i mean
yourself with a knife
no because the mama lion is is out to
get you like the mama lions well the
pack of wolves is too yeah
i trust myself with eight bullets and i
probably closed my eyes too you know i
you know i'm i'm a peaceful guy i don't
you know i feel bad if like they were
out to get me i had to like put them
down close your eyes and shoot the
wolves yeah
tell you what if you shoot with your
high schools i wouldn't trust yours no
you're right
well you got to think too but the mama
line would scare the [ __ ] out of me i
don't know what i would do i'd probably
run the fact that i got a gun i feel
like i'd be more like
ready to take them on
what's the youngest age child that could
beat you up [ __ ] none of them
probably like probably like well like
let them beat me up probably like
this is you are fighting for your life
i'm fighting for my life none of them
not a single one you think there's no 16
year old that could beat you up like a
16 you know who probably could yeah
probably okay but that's not a child
that's not a child okay i'll cap it at
14.
cause then 14 you started some hair on
your balls you had puberty so you might
you might be running into like a grown
man you ever seen one of them grown mans
that's 14 yeah yeah yeah so 14 is the
cat over the league world series yeah
yeah yeah i am 12.
you go over to like russia though man
you got these kids who bunch of [ __ ]
trees yeah 14 years old but then no no
one's hit people training up the fight
no one's hitting puberty at eight years
old he was fighting bears when he was a
kid you don't think he could beat you up
yeah now that i think about it more i
think i'd probably go with like the age
of 10. would you rather throw up any
time someone says mcdonald's or wear
fedora for the rest of your life and if
anybody asks about it you have to say i
like the way it looks
i [ __ ] hate for doors i probably
throw up anytime someone says mcdonald's
because if you think about like when's
the last time someone said mcdonald's
but you know what you couldn't do you
you couldn't tell someone that you throw
up every time you say mcdonald's because
then you get some prick oh my gosh
i like it
way too much dude
mcdonald's
i haven't heard the word mcdonald's in
in forever honestly
you know what that card should have said
she said chick-fil-a then i would have
had to think about it
if there was a snail following you for
the rest of your life and if you touched
it you'd die how long could you survive
so i'll give it up we couldn't fit the
whole thing on a car this is a snail
that is it knows who you are it wants to
touch you it wants to kill you
and it's going to come after you your
whole life it's still that tiny snail
but it's like you go to sleep at night
it might be creeping up your bed and
touch you and you're dead you know what
i would do
i would go right next to the snail okay
to the point to where it get killed no
to the point to where it couldn't touch
me okay and then i would buy a ticket
halfway across the globe on an airplane
i gotta worry about that so now come
with me forever i'll go to hawaii how's
the snail gonna get me in hawaii it's
gonna go get on a plane
can you do that
honestly i think natural causes would
kill me before the snail did so i think
i'd be all right would you rather have
the ability to drink with no hangover to
be and to be able to pull any girl at
the bar or become friends with joe pesci
i think i want to be friends with joe
pesci because if you drink with no
hangover
like to me what makes me not drink is
the hangover you know what i'm saying so
like to have no hangover you probably
think you're invincible you get really
fat and then you don't perform in the
gym you know what i'm saying so
to pull any girl at the bar you know
what i mean like if you don't strike out
every now and then you don't learn
nothing so i think i'd rather become
friends with joe pesci and then i could
tell everybody like you know i know joe
pesci imagine the instagrams yeah i'll
be unbelievable
if you got a one-time pass to do
whatever you wanted what crime would you
commit i'd go 150 miles an hour
everywhere i went but not you listen
everyone watching i wouldn't do it in a
residential area i would do it on the
highway but to be able to speed wherever
i wanted to or not do like 30 and a 30
or something like that that'd be great
if you're continuously getting attacked
by eagles at one time how many could you
kill before they got to you
uh
they're no [ __ ] you ever see the
talons on the eagles you ever see the
goats on the mountain and the eagle
comes in
and throws in the [ __ ] goat goes
flying probably one or two to be honest
that's zero i think yeah i wanted to say
zero but i didn't want you to be like
zero like meathead coming from the sky
two they got the upper hand yeah not
that probably
maybe one oh [ __ ]
you got enough film on this one
what is the one food you could eat for
the rest of your life i could eat a
bacon egg and cheese with salt pepper
ketchup on an everything bagel fresh
though for the rest of my life breakfast
lunch and dinner if you are aware that
the sausage is far superior
it's also joking i think that is
actually a like borderline criminal
statement what you just said
no because
listen i would eat a bacon and cheese
soap i would catch up the rest of my
life and then italian food
like obviously everyone would say pizza
but like my magnona makes a really good
eggplant parmesan it's out of this world
it's like the most amazing thing because
she burns the top with the parmesan and
then you cut the thing in and you go to
eat it and it's like you get the
crispiness from the parmesan but then
like the juiciness from the the
breadcrumbs and and everything like that
um
yeah i think i'm gonna change my answer
now and do the eggplant parmesan
for the best food i can eat for the rest
of my life
thank you so much i appreciate you guys
having me seriously
thank you for watching answer the
internet please remember to subscribe to
the channel
set reminders with a little bell
comment who you want to see do it and
watch all the other answer the internets
i don't know where anything is so i'm
kind of just moving my hands around but
do all that [ __ ] subscribe comment
reminder watch others you're welcome
don't know why but you're welcome